عمل 2022 ما خلى ولا اقتصاد عالمي بحاله
عواصف كثير حروب ازمه مناخ طاقه وصولا
كمان لتضخم اللي انهجت دول كثير كبيره في
العالم لدرجه يا جماعه انه صار الاكل
والملابس عم يشكلوا تحدي لا كثير من الناس
اليوم دراسه اللي عم نحكي عنها اجرتها
شركه الاستشارات كيف يعني جي وكشفت انه
نحو الثلثي الاشخاص اللي يشملهم الاستطلاع
والبالغ عددهم 3,000 شخص ببريطانيا عبروا
عن حاجتهم لخفض الانفاق وتوجه نحو او
التوجه كمان نحو التوفير والسبب اكيد هو
التضخم اللي بلغ اعلى مستوياته في
بريطانيا في اخر اربعه عقود وجده الدراسه
كمان انه مستهين عم يدفعوا اكثر مقابل
الاساسيات مثل الطعام والرهون العقاريه
وفواتير الطاقه
اكثر من هيك كمان الدراسه البريطانيه وجدت
انه نصف المشمولين بالاستطلاع هما بيسعوا
عم حاليا يسحبوا المدخلاتهم لمساعدتهم على
تلبيه التكاليف الاساسيه بس